whether you love it hate it I've never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up senators frank
Lautenberg and Dick Durbin for
pressuring baseball's Biggs tube and
chewing tobacco and a lawyer DUP Lindsay
Lohan who used a lawsuit to bully
talking toddlers at milkaholic Lindsay
wasn't over lelo claims the etrade
commercial references her and a
settlement agreement reportedly
prohibits the little tykes from saying
Lindsey or milkaholic not alive but
there can be only one nanny of the month
in this time it's US Senator Harry Reid
the time has come to outlaw prostitution
brothels are legal in some of Nevada's
rural counties and Reid says that irked
an out of state business owner who was
considering opening up shop in Harry's
home state so let's have an adult
conversation about an adult subject ok
well [ __ ] adults have the right to
engage in consensual acts with other
adults and Vegas bands prostitution but
that hasn't stopped the world's oldest
profession there's 32,000 illegal
prostitutes there's been four hundred
girls arrested working with HIV and what
about that business owner he simply
couldn't believe that one of the biggest
businesses and the county he was
considering for his new home is legal
prostitution but the guy is still
bringing his business to Nevada now
wonder why Reid didn't mention that
check back next month for more examples
of busybodies minding your own business